bene ragazzi perduti questo video sono
famigliari benvenuti su midnight sims
che dovrebbe essere scene di mezzanotte
cioè che ti chiami o copta vi è un
horror lo zio è un horror ha così
proprio si parte bella alla grafica
player bance 29 anni lei sta per
scoprire gli orrori prima strada isolata
oscura e deserta un incidente cambierà
la sua vita per sempre
e la sua percezione della realtà
cos'è radio maria mettiamo la radio
normale mettiamo radio deejay dove radio
deejay e non spegniamo proprio perfetto
cioè ho spento la radio al gioco della
l'episodio di stasera di ai tuoi dovrei
forse dirlo con una faccia un po più
profonda per rendere un po allora farò
questo commentare tutto così la donna
mentre guidava ha sbattuto contro un
palo della luce perché le donne non
sanno vi daranno non era lei era caduto
da solo perfetto è
non era un pregiudizio e pensavo avesse
sbattuto sul serio oh mio dio è caduto
un palo della luce con la corrente
proviamo a camminarci sopra che mi
sembra un'idea della madonna
magari clea dovrebbe cercare qualche
aiuto per ricominciare il suo viaggio il
prima possibile
sì perché girare attorno al ballo era
difficile quindi fortunatamente vede un
segnale della cabina del telefono
auguriamo buona fortuna
questa è la cabina del telefono ma non
puoi semplicemente prendere la macchina
in cui dare via no frega niente se non
vale allora scendi e fai le cose a piedi
che devo dire se questa roba che è il
trump in e vabbè c'è un'immagine di un
bambino sul muro dovrebbe staccare la
corrente come faccio a salvatore non
puoi seguire questa donna non è capace
di fare il giro alle cose non è capace e
non ci posso andare il dato ha stancato
corrente come un attacco la corrente
accenni radio maria magari gesù ci aiuta
no c'è qualcosa possa aggirare
l'ostacolo bene quel bambino con una
faccia normale grazie a dio permesso
presentarci qualcos'altro a destra c'è
qualcos'altro
scommetto che un bambino apro questo
bambino normale grazie a dio perché poi
non c'è niente che entriamo va bene
ecco invece no questo ero io che guidava
la macchina ma e sangue questo e
petrolio
credo sia sangue giudicare dal fatto che
non è che guidava il bambino dopo che se
guidava lui allora grazie a stage epa
che hanno sbattuto bella la macchina
comunque in fumo ho trovato un capello
beh dai usi le cose andavano uno
spaventapasseri che bello più dure
bellissimo al trovato il braccio dello
spaventapasseri va bene dove lo metto
[Musica]
avevo fatto da collegare legato perfetto
no perché scavalcare era difficile no
quindi mettiamo un marchingegno dentro
lo spaventapasseri giustamente
l'atmosfera è veramente incredibile
rarefatto da dio il problema è che non
so sono entrati in casa propria
permesso credo che qualcuno abbia perso
tanto sangue però è una deduzione mia
ma io devo dedurre la storia a questo è
un famoso quadro cielo presente anche la
tv di the ring magari anche no grazie ai
ragazzi le tracce di sangue e portano al
bagno permesso grazie arrivederci ma me
ne frega niente di questo c'è del mago
che dai controlliamo questo punto altri
proprio controllare saggio video del
gioco mai controllare un morto in una
stanza buia regola numero uno degli
horror a c'è anche la parte sul retro
alla casa sull'albero finissimo non ci
arrivo è un pesce a una tegola di legno
va bene credo che sia per arrampicare
rapida di fila nel nell'albero
arrampicata martello in teoria però
vabbè ho picchiato ce l'abbiamo manca
come spingerlo per ora senza il martello
con le mani cioè io metto il coso fa coi
pugni
no ragazzi devo trovare un martello
qualcuno c'è un martello da prestarmi
dopo ci sono degli attrezzi non me n'ero
accorto proprio regala niente torniamo
indietro celo celo martello ce lo
godiamo questi due
ok perfetto è pronto a salire salire con
così tanta naturalezza però va bene ok
faccio mi suicido unalat è tutto sto
casino per una lanterna ma veramente
cosa me ne faccio a entrò nel bagno e
faccio luce va beh ma da evitare
mamma mia oh dio tutto sto casino per
far luce dentro il bagno vi rendete
conto
allora frate
capiamoci io ti vengo a salutare ma del
piano è ma il padre ma a qualcosa di
conficcato nella testa
tipo un no ho trovato una chiave però va
bene via via ma la mamma e il figlio
esattamente dove che sono sempre facili
nata a è vero c'è sempre il furgone
cielo è cosa da prima che la chiave ok
perfetto cosa me ne faccio delle cesoie
il piccone la palla
minecraft non ho capito e ci sono io
servono per passare con la macchina
quindi c'è la fine ho fatto tutto sto
bordello perché devo passare con la
macchina ma veramente c'entravano per
tagliare questo credo quasi un'ora e
mezza per passare da questo punto
incredibile ma che sono arrivato alla
parte del telefono non prendervi il
telefono un genio possono fare e vado
avanti
ma in teoria c'era un telefono prima
questo è successo qua
ragazzi ma se non sapete guidare lui
guidate c'erano profitto giorno mi
dispiace che sia andata così la capra
non guidate non siete capaci voglio dire
chi è questo sì proprio se dovete far
capire una storia attraverso delle note
almeno scrivente non scrivete
scarabocchi
non capisco che c'è scritto non hanno
rai che possa andare intuito capire del
telefono pronto non pesa lo fa
[Musica]
salve vorrei mai fare questa cosa che
sto facendo
quando si dice avere una personalità
elettrica claims burns del 29 anni era
già detto con grande e forte credo sia
la escort è riuscita a riprendere il suo
viaggio ancora terrorizzata si è fermata
la prima stazione per contattare le
autorità informarle degli eventi che
sono accaduti nulla fuori dall'ordinario
e stato trovato dalla polizia
nessun incidente sono presenza di
qualche misterioso bambino l'uomo che
viveva nella fattoria è stato trovato un
po ubriaco ma ancora in buone condizioni
lei è tornata alla sua vita di tutti i
giorni cercando di convincersi che non
era pazza dopotutto probabilmente lei ha
visto qualcosa che non avrebbe dovuto
mai vedere
ottavi navarro
questo barattolo di vetro ha una trama
più bella di questo è ok bravo tavina
varano per aver fatto questo gioco
signor navarro lavoro
lei era l'uomo ubriaco in buone
condizioni filippo cattolica questi
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto al strumento è
un mi piace scusatemi siano un po breve
non pensavo neanche fosse così breve
però era carica come sono un mito che vi
piace anche senza circuito della
descrizione sono esistite rivediamo
prossimo visto
[Musica]